tenemos el siguiente problema supongamos
que a islas un ácido de unas hojas de
trébol y sabes que contiene únicamente
los elementos carbono hidrógeno y
oxígeno muy bien dice calentando 0.500
13 gramos del ácido junto con oxígeno se
producen 0.500 1 gramos de dióxido de
carbono y 0 puntos 103 gramos de agua ok
cuál es la fórmula empírica del ácido
que pues tendrá la fórmula c x h y y
ceta muy bien entonces vamos a ir
anotando la reacción que en realidad
está proponiendo nuestro problema
tenemos nuestro ácido de la cual más
bien del cual no conocemos cuantos
carbonos tiene tampoco sabemos cuántos
hidrógenos tiene y tampoco sabemos
cuántos oxígenos tiene sin embargo si
sabemos que son los únicos elementos que
que contiene y este ácido va a
reaccionar junto con el oxígeno el
oxígeno por supuesto que se presenta en
el aire y nos va a producir nos va a
producir cierta cantidad de dióxido de
carbono y de agua muy bien entonces solo
solo con esta información ni siquiera
podríamos balancear la ecuación porque
no sabemos cuántos carbonos hidrógenos y
oxígeno
tiene este ácido sin embargo si sabemos
cuántos gramos de cada uno de los
reactivos y de los productos tenemos
entonces tenemos que se calientan 0.500
13 gramos del ácido entonces tenemos
0.500 13 gramos y tenemos oxígeno en
abundancia así que este nunca nos va a
faltar y se producen 0.500 1 gramos de
dióxido de carbono y 0 puntos 103 gramos
agua muy bien entonces lo que tenemos
aquí es es un problema muy parecido al
que hemos resuelto en ocasiones
anteriores sólo que para obtener la
fórmula empírica lo que aquí tenemos es
o más bien tenemos que revisar las
proporciones que hay entre tres
sustancias o entre tres tipos de
elementos entre el carbono el hidrógeno
y el oxígeno muy bien así que hay que
encontrar la proporción entre estos tres
lo que vamos a hacer es primero
encontrar los moles los moles que
tenemos de dióxido de carbono el dióxido
de carbono o más bien debería subrayar
aquí los gramos de estos de esta
cantidad de gramos de dióxido de carbono
podemos obtener el número de moles que
tenemos de dióxido de carbono esto
inmediatamente me va a decir cuántos
moles de carbono tengo porque si te das
cuenta en los productos el único que
contiene carbono es el dióxido de
carbono mientras que en el lado de los
reactivos el único que contiene carbono
es justamente
nuestro ácido muy bien ahora el que no
es directo es encontrar la cantidad de
moles que tenemos de oxígeno porque
tenemos del lado de los productos
tenemos en cada una de estas dos
sustancias oxígeno sin embargo lo que
podemos obtener es el número de moles
que necesitamos o más bien que obtenemos
de agua porque nuevamente es el único
que contiene hidrógenos y así podríamos
obtener el número de moles que tenemos
de hidrógenos del lado de los reactivos
una vez que sepamos la masa de carbono y
de hidrógeno podremos saber la masa del
oxígeno que tenemos en esta sustancia y
después veremos la cantidad de moles y
finalmente podremos ver la la proporción
que hay entre ellos yo sé que a lo mejor
puede confundir esto pero pero
resolviendo los se van a aclarar
muchísimo el digamos los métodos y los
conceptos que estamos trabajando así que
vamos a empezar vamos a empezar con el
carbono tenemos cero
punto 500 1 gramos de dióxido de carbono
muy bien y nosotros queremos saber
cuántos moles de dióxido de carbono
tenemos así que tenemos que multiplicar
por algo que digamos por uno por una a
un número que sea moles de dióxido de
carbono sobre gramos de dióxido de
carbono de esta forma podríamos cancelar
los gramos y quedarnos sólo con los
moles ahora cuántos gramos tiene cada
molde dióxido de carbono pues pensemos
que el carbono tiene una una masa
atómica de 12 y el oxígeno tiene una
masa atómica de 16 pero tenemos dos así
que tenemos 2 por 16 que son 32 más 12
son 44 así que 44 gramos de dióxido de
carbono tenemos por cada molde esa
sustancia si nosotros queremos esto
entonces tenemos que por cada mol
tenemos 44 gramos y esto es lo que hay
que multiplicar para obtener el número
de mol
es los gramos se cancelan y lo que
obtenemos son 501 entre 44 así que voy a
sacar la calculadora
así que sacamos la calculadora y tenemos
que dividir 501 entre 44 44 y obtenemos
11 punto no no no no qué pasó lo hicimos
mal en realidad era 0.500 o no verdad
0.500 1 entre 44 ahora sí y esto nos da
0.0 11 386 vamos a redondear lo a 0.01
14 muy bien 0.01 14
entonces son 0.01 14 moles de dióxido de
carbono muy bien
ahora bien fijémonos que por cada
molécula de dióxido de carbono tenemos
un átomo un átomo de carbono es decir
por cada molde de dióxido de carbono
tengo un molde de carbono esto nos
implica inmediatamente que tenemos 0.01
14 moles moles de carbono ahora ven
ahora bien en que quiero saber cuánto o
cuántos gramos tenemos de carbono así
que ahora tenemos que volver a hacer la
conversión de las de las de digamos de
las unidades y lo que sí sabemos es que
por cada 12 gramos de carbono yo tengo
mol de carbono así que hacemos esta
conversión y qué es lo que nos queda los
moles nuevamente se cancelan y hay que
multiplicar 0.01 14 por 12 bien y que
justamente aquí ya lo tenemos
simplemente multiplicamos por 12 y esto
nos da 0.1 366 vamos a redondear lo a 0
punto 137 así que tenemos cero punto
137 gramos de carbono muy bien ahora
vamos con el siguiente vamos a trabajar
ahora con el hidrógeno muy bien entonces
tenemos lo siguiente tengo cero punto
103 gramos de agua vamos a ver cuántos
moles tenemos entonces tenemos 0.0
perdón 0 puntos 103 gramos de agua
y queremos convertirlo a moles así que
tenemos que multiplicar por algo que
tenga más bien arriba queremos moles
moles de agua entre gramos de agua ahora
bien cómo obtenemos cuántos gramos hay
por cada mol pues cada hidrógeno tiene
una masa atómica de 2 y bueno perdón
tiene cada uno tiene una masa atómica de
1 pero tenemos dos verdad tenemos dos
hidrógenos y luego sumamos 16 que es la
masa atómica del oxígeno y esto
simplemente nos da 18 es decir tenemos
18 gramos de agua por cada mol y si
hacemos esta multiplicación lo que nos
queda es simplemente dividir 0 puntos
103 entre 18 entonces tenemos cero punto
entre 18 y eso nos da 0.005 72 vamos a
dejarlo hasta ahí esto nos da 0.005 72
moles
moles de agua moles de agua ahora bien
recordemos como siempre lo hemos hecho
que por cada molde agua tenemos dos de
hidrógeno esto quiere decir que si
quieren lo podemos hacer con la
conversión tengo 0.005 72 moles de agua
pero por cada molde agua por cada molde
agua
yo tengo dos moles de hidrógeno verdad
pues y en cada en cada una de estas
moléculas aparecen dos átomos de
hidrógeno entonces si nosotros hacemos
esta conversión tenemos dos moles de
hidrógeno que hay que multiplicar por
0.005 72 que es justamente lo que
teníamos aquí y si multiplicamos por 2
obtenemos 0.01 1 4444 hasta que se acabe
en verdad
entonces esto vamos a redondear lo como
0.01 14
entonces esto es 0.01 14 sí sí lo
recuerdo bien si estamos bien y estos
son moles de hidrógeno moles de
hidrógeno ya tenemos cuántos moles de
hidrógeno tenemos ahora queremos saber
cuál es la masa la masa de de la masa
total de hidrógenos que tenemos en esta
reacción entonces vamos a multiplicar
vamos a hacer la conversión verdad
porque por cada gramo de hidrógeno
tengo un molde de hidrógeno eso es lo
agradable del hidrógeno verdad cada
hidrógeno tiene una masa atómica de 1
así que si nosotros hacemos esta
multiplicación los moles de hidrógeno se
cancelan y obtenemos exactamente la
misma cantidad de gramos
vamos a dejarlo igual éstos eran 0.01 14
gramos
e hidrógeno y ya tenemos la cantidad de
gramos de hidrógenos que se tienen en
esta reacción muy bien a ver entonces en
resumen ya tenemos los moles de carbono
y los moles de hidrógeno verdad los
tenemos los tenemos aquí y los moles de
carbono ahora bien si podemos ver
cuántos moles de oxígeno en nuestro
ácido original si podemos ver cuántos
moles de hidro de persona de oxígeno
tenemos en nuestro ácido original
entonces podríamos calcular la
proporción más chica que tenemos entre
ellos y así encontrar nuestra fórmula
empírica pero para encontrar el número
de moles primero tenemos que saber
cuántos gramos de oxígeno tenemos y para
hacerlo tenemos el siguiente
procedimiento tengo la cantidad de
gramos total de nuestro ácido y tengo
también la cantidad de gramos de carbono
y la cantidad de gramos de oxígeno si yo
le quito estos 2
lo que me queda debe ser la cantidad de
gramos que tenemos de oxígeno así que
vamos a hacer
eso
vamos a hacer eso y tenemos 0.500 13
gramos 0 punto déjenme ponerlo con el
mismo color tengo 0.500 13 gramos de
nuestro ha sido desconocido
ha sido desconocido y si le quitamos si
le quitamos los cero puntos 137 gramos
de carbono que obtuvimos y después le
quitamos lo que teníamos de hidrógeno es
decir le quitamos 0.01 14 gramos de
hidrógeno lo que nos quitó o más bien lo
que nos quedamos es si le quitamos el
carbono y el hidrógeno pues nos quedamos
con la cantidad de gramos de oxígeno que
tiene este ácido y eso es vamos a
hacerlo vamos a hacer
0.500 13 menos
0 punto 137 menos vamos a ver
0.01 14 y eso nos da 0.3 646 lo voy a
redondear como 0.3 65
entonces tenemos 0.3 65 gramos de
oxígeno y ya vamos muy adelantados en
este problema ahora si yo quiero saber
la cantidad de moles simplemente hay que
convertirlos vamos a convertir los moles
entonces tengo 0.3 165 gramos de oxígeno
y vamos a ver por cada molde de oxígeno
cuántos gramos de oxígeno tenemos pues
cada oxígeno tiene una masa atómica de
16 entonces por cada mol tengo 16 gramos
de oxígeno así que esto simplemente se
reduce a que este número que obtuvimos
lo dividimos entre 16 y obtenemos 0.2
278 así que lo voy a redondear como 0.02
creo que sí lo había dicho bien en
realidad quise decir 0.02 28 y 0.02 28
moles de oxígeno y ya casi terminamos ya
estamos en la recta final porque ya
tenemos los moles de carbono aquí están
los moles de carbono
ya los marque tenemos los moles de
hidrógeno moles de hidrógeno y tenemos
los moles de oxígeno tenemos los moles
de oxígeno ya podemos calcular cuál es
la proporción entre ellos así que
queremos calcular la proporción de los
0.01 14 moles de carbono con respecto
a los moles de hidrógeno que es 0.01 14
moles de hidrógeno y también con
respecto a los moles de oxígeno que son
0.02 28 moles de oxígeno entonces así a
primera instancia lo que podemos ver es
que tenemos la misma cantidad de moles
de carbono que de hidrógeno y que
tenemos el doble de moles de oxígeno que
de hidrógeno entonces esto ya nos está
diciendo cuál es la fórmula empírica si
dividimos en en los tres digamos en
estas tres partes entre 0.0 114
si dividimos entre 0.0 114 0.01 14 lo
que obtenemos es lo siguiente
obtenemos estas mismas proporciones 0.01
14 entre 0.0 114 esto nos da un mol de
carbono
ahora si dividimos 0.01 14 entre 0.0 114
nos da 1
mol de hidrógeno y si dividimos 0.02 28
entre 0.0 114 si nos damos cuenta este
numerador es el doble que el denominador
así que esto nos da ponerlo con el mismo
color esto nos da
dos moles de oxígeno muy bien así que
esto ya nos dice cuál es la fórmula
empírica de nuestro ácido misterioso no
sabemos exactamente la fórmula molecular
pero sí sabemos las proporciones que
debe haber entre estas entre estos
átomos o la cantidad de de de átomos que
debe haber de carbono hidrógeno y
oxígeno en la fórmula del ácido entonces
la fórmula empírica es
un átomo de carbono
un átomo de hidrógeno y dos átomos de
oxígeno y esta es la fórmula empírica de
nuestro ácido misterioso así que ya que
lo hemos encontrado creo que no fue tan
difícil ir de verdad espero que te hayas
divertido